Where you have to remember when you
watch something like this movie,
not a single bit of it is random or
occidental,
none of it because you know they had to
draw,
I don't remember how many frames per
second these things are 30,
maybe.
Maybe it's a little less than that,
but it's high quality automation and so
someone had to paint 30 pictures to get
a second of this.
You're not doing that accidentally.
It's really expensive and everyone has
to agree on exactly what's going to
happen and you might say,
well,
do the people who are doing this
consciously know what they're doing?
And that answer of that is well,
sort of just like you do,
you know it's yes they know and no they
don't and they know because they're
really smart and gifted and all that,
but they don't know because it's not all
articulated.
Plus they're working in a group so they
know and don't know just like you do
when you're watching it and so and and
when you do anything else.
So now they're also guided by what you
might call.
They're guided by their unconscious in
the in the Friday and and in the
cognitive way,
partly because your unconscious value
structures determine the direction and
content of your perceptions and so it's
built right into the way you move your
eyes because you tend to look at things
you value right or things you're afraid
of,
like you look at things with valence and
part of the decision about what has
value is dependent on the implicit
structure of your moral system,
your purse,
because morality is about what's good
and what isn't,
and that's been partly a conscious
construction of you,
but it's partly something you've been.
You've picked up by interacting with
people like mad ever since you were
born.
You don't know all the rules anymore
than the damn cricket did.
You just don't and you can't because
you're too complicated,
but you act them out and then you also
have representations of how people act
in your imagination.
Dreams are.
That's what a dream is.
That's what a fantasy is.
That's what that little movie that plays
inside your head when you remember what
you did is,
and you only remember the just you know,
so even the the images stick
representation of your behavior in your
past,
which is basically your episodic memory.
It's already selecting and molding and
turning it into a relatable story.
It can't help but do that.
It's the only way you can represent it
and so you don't know how you do that or
why you do that,
but part of it's governed by this
implicit morality that's part of your
procedural memory system,
part of the way you act and part of the
way you move your eyes and listen to
things and focus on them and that's all
been instantiated inside of you because
of this immense social,
your biology,
but also this immense social project
that you're continually engaged in and
so that informs what you remembered.
It informs what you imagined.
It informs what we collectively
imagined.
It informs what we can collectively
understand and partly what you're doing
well,
you become conscious of yourself is to
map the implicit structures that already
constitute you from society into
explicit representation.
That's what self understanding means and
you know when you have that moment of
insight about you've done,
it's like you're watching your this
repetitive behavior that you've
manifested probably that got you in
trouble.
You know it's your characteristic way of
falling accidentally into chaos and you
talk about your problems.
You talk about them with your friends,
you talk about them and maybe you have
dreams about them and you're,
you're trying to relate them and you
have memories about them that you can't
get rid of because they're negatively
tones.
So you talk about them and then someone
comes up with a little statement that
links them together causally and you
think,
oh,
that's what I'm doing.
And then maybe you can stop doing it,
or at least,
or at least maybe.
Then you can think of some strategies
for not doing it anymore.
But it's not like,
you know,
it's like you're acting it out.
You know it that way.
But until that's all,
until the representation matches that
pattern,
that click of insight doesn't occur.
And that's like a revelation.
It's a really good way of thinking about
it because the knowledge is there and
it's implicit forum and all of a sudden
bang.
It's been made explicit as a fantasy
maybe or also as a,
as a set of semantic statements.
You know,
maybe you're,
you have a crush on someone and you
don't notice it.
And maybe you find yourself having a
fantasy about them.
You Think,
oh,
that means something that indicates
something.
Maybe you don't want him to know that
that's what you want.
But the fantasy will tell you.
And one of the things you suggested,
and this is sort of out of the Freudian
tradition of free associations,
is watch yourself.
Watch your fantasies because they're
always happening.
And so,
and they'll tell you something.
And so one of the things I do when,
when I'm interacting with my clients is
we'll have a discussion and then they'll
let their eyes will drift a little bit.
And I'll know that there are somethings
flitted through their mind,
you know?
And that means we've touched on
something that has multiple,
a multiplicity of elements,
and so I'll stop and say,
look,
I noticed that you maybe you tear it up,
that's another thing to really watch
her.
Maybe you laugh or you drifted.
At least it's like it's because some
other thought has entered your field of
consciousness.
And then if you can get the person to
grab those thoughts to notice them,
then you can often figure out the
avenues along which that particular
conversation might unfold.
That's a complex,
that's a union complex or a
psychoanalytic complex.
It's like there's an emotional core that
produces a whole range of associated
ideas and that thing's got a life.
It's like a micro personality and it
might have resentment and it might have
anger.
It's often negative emotion tinge
because the negative emotion tinge to
episodes are still problems and they
will emerge automatically because your
threat detection systems force them onto
your consciousness essentially.
So you watch and where when you drift,
you will drift.
And the fantasy is partly a
representation of the problem space.
You know that happens when you wake up
at three in the morning and you're
worried about things,
right?
Because actually what happens is you
wake up during threat processing and if
you're depressed actually that gets so
intense you can't sleep,
so then you just lay there all night
worrying,
not fun,
and those are fantasies about the
negative elements of your past,
present and future,
and the fantasies can also breed
solutions.
And that's partly why Freud regard
dreams as wish fulfillments.
It's partly that and he wasn't.
That was where he stopped.
It's not correct.
It's partially correct.
It's like the fantasy will provide you
with a problem and a potential solution,
but they're more like problem
identification mechanisms.
The fantasies with the possibility of a
solution built in and so a way of
thinking about that is that you can
generate potential futures so they're
like each segregated environments
according to the rules of your fantasy.
Then you can generate little avatars of
yourself that didn't have at each of
those little universes and you can run
them as simulations and then you can
watch what happens in the simulation and
if it's a catastrophe then you don't
have to act it out and that's exactly
not exactly.
That's akin to what you're doing when
you go watch a movie,
except that is much more coherent and
well thought through,
you know,
and then than just a dream which is
often quite fragmentary.
And that's partly because the dream is
willing to sacrifice coherence to play
with category structures,
you know,
and that's why in dreams things can
change from one thing into another
really weirdly or scenes can change from
one scene to another without a logic.
The logic gets loosened so that the
experience of your thinking can widen
and it's,
it's,
it's dangerous to do that.
And that's partly why you do it when
you're asleep and paralyzed,
you know,
you don't run around and act out your,
your suit,
a puddle fantasies,
you know,
where you're stretching yourself out
into the world.
There's no risk.
Exactly.
And so,
although it can be bad enough,
so you'll wake up in terror,
you know,
but that's better than being in a
crocodile's mouth by a large margin.